Референдум у Каталонії розпалює апетит
іспанських сепаратистів.
Наступним регіоном, який забажає незалежності,
може стати автономна область Іспанії -
Країна Басків.
Тут так само сепаратисти протягом десятиліть
борються за відокремлення від Іспанії.
І так само посилаються на власну мову та культуру.
Жорсткі дії поліції в Каталонії обурили багатьох
басків, зокрема студентів.
"Два народи, одна боротьба" -
написано на цьому плакаті в університеті.
Чимало басків підтримують каталонців і також
хочуть самостійно вирішувати питання незалежності.
Каталонський рух за незалежність
потужніший за баскський.
Але у наших заявах солідарності люди знову і знову
наголошують на тому, що теж хочуть незалежності.
На хвилі подій у Каталонії питання
баскської незалежності знову стає актуальним,
каже фахівець з конституційного права Роберто Уріарте.
І те, що раніше було справою екстремістських партій
та угруповання ЕТА, тепер переростає у ширший рух.
Щойно заклик до більшої свободи,
більшої демократії, прямої участі через референдум
стане голоснішим,  щойно регіон стане на цей шлях,
люди, які не належать до баскських націоналістів,
можуть стати радикальнішими, сильнішими.
Втім, баски вже були свідками того,
як боротьба за незалежність
може завершитися насиллям.
Навіть якщо після десятиліть терору організації ЕТА
нарешті запанував мир.
Все може бути як у Каталонії. Але може бути й гірше,
радикальніше, ніж раніше.
Продавчиня газет Ізабель Лопатегі зберігає спокій
і бачить позитив у тому, що люди мобілізуються
і беруть майбутнє у свої руки.
Мене це не лякає. Навпаки – я бачу бажання людей
показати, ким вони є і що вони хочуть бути вільними.
Жінку не дивує, що після застосування сили
проти каталонців під час референдуму
все більше людей схиляються до незалежності -
як у Каталонії, так і у Країні Басків.